bonjour et merci à d'être avec nous sur
rtl france à leur première question qui
fait écho aux propos d'olivier verront
pas de deuxième vague donc en france
pour l'instant pas de deuxième vague
c'est heureux les les jeux les toujours
17 sept
cette deuxième vague est possible et
parce qu'elle est possible doit être
évitable ça veut dire que chacun d'entre
nous doit respecter les gestes barrière
chacun d'entre nous il doit porter le
masque un lieu clos ou quand on se
trouve l'un des citations de
concentration très importante de
population soit des petits périmètres à
l'extérieur se laver les mains
régulièrement et avoir un comportement
sérieux pour éviter qu'elle arrive pour
l'instant elle n'est pas là elle
pourrait arriver donc on doit continuer
à respecter ces fameux gestes et ses
fameux geste en ces gestes barrières
selon louis sont assez respectés par les
français côté on a quand même une nette
amélioration depuis que le port du
masque est devenu obligatoire un lieu
clos depuis ces deux tribunes de
médecins et la réponse du gouvernement
qui a été accélérée par jean castex dans
sa mise en place
on voit quand même que les choses ont
changé et on voit beaucoup plus de
personnes qui portent des masques alors
après di roma ce biais dire aux gens
porter les masques tout le temps à
l'extérieur et c'est alors même qu' il
va faire 41 degrés dans certains
endroits
je crois qu'il faut que l'on ait une à
la fois une compréhension du pourquoi on
porte ce masque et puis que l'on
permette aux gens de pouvoir vivre les
de pouvoir respirer convenablement avec
la chaleur dans les endroits où il n'y a
pas de risque de transmission de la
contamination
je veux dire par là que un extérieur
quand on est sur une plage ou dans une
rue il n'y a pas trop de vent debout
ça sert à rien de porter le masque par
contre quand on est vraiment en quoi
cette passion là il faut le mettre
alors est ce qu'on réalise à ces deux
tests de dépistage en france mais pas
encore assez on a vu qu'on avait prévu
on l'avait annoncé le gouvernement à
verser 700 villes tests vous savez lors
du discours le 28 avril du discours de
mise en place de déconfinement on
l'avait annoncé 700 mille tests pour le
promet une somme le
30 juillet le 31 on évite à 380 mille
quatre cent mille péniblement ça monte
doucement la problématique structurelle
il n'y a pas assez de bras pour faire
cesser ces tests peut-être faut-il
ouvrir ces tests ou cabinets médicaux
aux infirmières aux pharmacies en plus
des professions qui vont leur donner le
droit de pratiquer ces tests dans un
laboratoire
alors une question parce que on teste
c'est vrai mais les gens qui se font tc
dans les laboratoires dans les
pharmacies fin peu importe
après quand ils ont les résultats et
rentrer chez eux ne se met pas forcément
en quarantaine alors quelle est la
stratégie sur le long terme de tester
des gens si après on les confine pas si
vous avez tout dit et le problème c'est
que si d'un latin est en attente du
résultat vous devez évidemment rester
chez vous et porter le masque
alors là pour le coup en tous lieux pour
éviter de contaminer autour de vous et
puis si le résultat du test est positif
vous devez vous confinés pendant 14
jours comme c'était le cas pendant la
période de mars et d'avril comme le pro
vite tapé fort
donc il faut il faut être s'est
sectionné que de la logique tout ce à
quoi il faut si l'on fait le test c'est
pour avoir un diagnostic dans l'atteinte
de diagnostic on doit faire comme si le
test était positif
si le test est négatif on ressort on
peut reprendre une vie normale mais
adapté à la présence du virus
et si le test est positif à somme allant
de rester chez soit confiné et protéger
son entourage
alors gagner à propos de ce spécialiste
britannique selon lesquelles il y aurait
certainement une deuxième vague autour
de l'automne et des univers et puis
cette fois ci ça pourrait toucher et les
jeunes qu'est ce que vous y pensez qu
est ce que vous en pensez mais côté je
vous rappelle pas madame irma donc je
n'ai pas de boule de cristal je peux pas
vous dire si c'est vrai ou faux ce que
je sais c'est que il y à une
augmentation progressive du nombre de
contaminations certes on teste plus mais
il y à une augmentation que cette
augmentation risque fort d'entraîner un
essaimage de la présence du virus sur
l'ensemble du territoire ce qui est
quand même profondément différentes
voilà vécu une première vague je me
rappelle que le virus était cantonné à
l'est et puis à l'ile-de-france et que
l'on a pu le plan de la zone là qu'il
n'a pas débordé ou très peu sur le reste
du territoire là en ayant dressé mais
toucher beaucoup de jeu
qui sont une paupiette une population à
forte interaction sociale tout laisse à
penser qu'il va être présent partout sur
tout le territoire et donc si l'on à une
deuxième vague
elle sera partout et c'est pour cela il
faut l'éviter est en tout cas il faut
l'éviter au mois d'août qui est la
période où on manque de soignants ou les
hôpitaux sont en tension et où les
personnels de soignants sont épuisés
jérôme marty merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin et président du
syndicat l'union française pour une
médecine libre merci